So 7.2, we call it falsehood and this lesson really is a response to a common atheist objection
that if God was so big and mighty and powerful and sovereign and all good,
then he would have prevented evil.
He wouldn't have allowed it in the first place.
I mean, think about it, if God can do these things, if God can just speak
and suddenly we have a universe, then why can't he prevent evil?
Years ago, I did a debate with an atheist and this was sort of his argument.
His argument was pretty complex, but let me sort of summarize it as quickly as I can.
He basically said that if God existed, God would have created a world
in which only God-like objects existed and he called that God-world.
And if this God-world were an actual world, then all the pieces of God-world would be just like God.
There would be no suffering, there would be no evil, there would be no nothing.
Everything would be absolutely perfect on equal playing field to God.
And my response was pretty simple.
It took me some time to figure out exactly what he was saying and then it hit me.
I said, well, one, why do you think this is the case?
And he said, well, because there's evil and suffering in the world.
I said, well, let's put that aside for a second.
Is there anything that God cannot do?
And he said, well, if God is all-powerful, then there's nothing that God cannot do.
That's why if he can't prevent evil, then God must not exist.
I said, that's not the case.
Just because God is all-powerful and sovereign and omniscient and all-awesome,
then does that mean that there's nothing that God cannot do?
So unfortunately, the old song, my God is so great, my God is so big,
there's nothing that's actually not necessarily true.
Because God could not create a world in which only God-like objects or God-like things,
that are equivalent to him, existed.
Because if that were the case, then God would not exist,
because he wouldn't be God anymore.
He would just be equal to everything else, then everything would be the same as God
and all things would be God, and that would take us into a form of pantheism.
So his argument didn't work.
But it's sort of this understanding that, well, why wouldn't God do that?
Well, because simply put, there's some things that God actually cannot do.
And what's important about this lesson is to help students understand that
God is not the one that's responsible for evil.
God did not create it.
It's like I've said last week, it's not a thing to be created because evil is not a thing.
God did not create it. God is not responsible.
And although God is doing something to remedy the situation,
he still has to allow us to have free will to make our own choices.
So this week, I would get your students thinking about the character and nature of who God is.
Have them think about, just like in the intro activity,
we ask them about things that it's impossible for humanity to do,
but what about things that are impossible for God to do?
What are some other things that maybe God cannot do?
Have your students sort of think that through of what makes God God
and what maybe limits does God actually have?
Now I don't mean fun things like can God create a rock so big
he can't lift it in those strange questions like that.
That's not what I'm talking about.
But things like God cannot contradict himself.
God cannot lie.
So have your students think that through to help paint a better picture
of the nature of God and exactly what he's doing in this world
to remedy the evil and the suffering that is so prevalent.
So God has morally justified reasons for allowing the temporary existence
of evil and suffering in our world.
That may seem like a cop out, like what?
That's the best you've got.
But remember what Scripture says and what Paul says in 1 Corinthians
is that we only see things in part right now.
We don't have a full picture.
There's still quite a bit of mystery going on.
The example I always used to give my students was
the example of being a kid or parenting my own kids
is that I may know what's best for my kids.
They may not realize that I know what's best
and what I'm telling them they have to do
or what I'm putting them through
may seem like a terrible, terrible thing for them in that moment.
The whole world is coming crashing down on them
yet I know exactly what I'm doing and it's for their good.
And that may be the case sometimes
and sometimes it's just the case that evil is just evil
and evil just happens.
And God doesn't like it any more than we do
but he has to allow it even if only for a time.
And as we'll see later on
when we get to more of the pastoral approach
to this question of evil
is that it can be used for something exceptionally good.
So in your small groups
I want you to start to brainstorm a little bit
about what good can come from evil.
But I also want you to again be very aware
when I keep beating this drum
be very aware of the questions that are coming.
If the questions didn't come last week
they may be coming this week
and they may be coming next week
they may be coming all of the weeks.
And be aware of some of the things
that your students are going through.
By now you probably know your students really well
you probably know their families
you probably have talked with their parents
and you've connected with their families on some level.
Do your best to be aware of some of the things
that your students are going through
for two reasons.
One so you can pray with them
and pastor them along and walk with them
and be there for them in the way that you need to be.
That goes without saying.
But the other is when we're dealing with these kinds of issues
you want to have an awareness and a sensitivity
so that you don't say anything
that would touch the wrong nerve
with your students.
Sometimes you may want to a little bit
to get a response out of students
and to move them along
but you also want to be very very very aware
of where they are
so that you can minister to them
the best possible way
without saying them back at all.
So rather than going down the easy road
and just simply doubting God
because of the evil that we see around us
we can actually look to him for hope
and know that he has a plan
know that he has a purpose
and know that of all the things that we're going through
it's not for nothing.
We can look to him for significant hope.